hello believe nation I'm Evan Carmichael
my one word is believe and I believe
that entrepreneurs are going to solve
all of the major problems of the world
so to help you on your journey today
we're going to learn from Pastor Sunday
at Elisha and my take on his top ten
rules of success rule number four is my
personal favorite and I'd love to know
which one you guys like the best and as
always guys as you're watching if you
hear something that really resonates
with you please leave it down the
comments below
put quotes around it so other people can
be inspired and when you write it down
it's much more likely to stick for
yourself as well enjoy
stop picking yourself
stop picking yourself top you know
looking at yourself at 8:50 that is one
thing you must stop doing if you want to
attend anything in life you know what
life is about pain everybody one time or
the other feels pain and if you offer
the pain or you want to run away from
pain all the time that means you pity
yourself too much and if you run away
too much from pain then you not that you
would love you you not you would not
have any progress or you not experience
any change in life whatsoever every
change requires pain for example if you
want to just sit down at too much study
and not watch TV and not go to play with
your with your or your friends that cost
something that causes some pain if you
want to be different from all that
people people criticize you and talk
about you that causes some pain but
those pain of what I call voluntary
pains they obtain that you need to pay
the price off right now so that you'll
be able to avoid greater pain later on
in life so but if you had somebody that
likes comfort too much and you think
that any correction or any process of
pain is too much for you or you deadly
for you or is unbearable for you you
only pity repeating yourself and if you
are just doing if all what you're doing
is just between yourself you will never
become a better person sometimes we all
need to be tough on ourselves
they tough on yourself get that your
flesh out of that day and go do what you
need to do sometimes you
to force your flesh to listen don't let
the flesh up dominion over you get to do
what you need to do and let that flesh
feel that pain so that you might get the
result that you desire in your life stop
between yourself now success is a one
thing that is hidden in the most
unlikely of places and one of the places
that success is hitting is in doing what
you don't feel like doing most of the
time we do what we feel like doing and
we do we don't do what we don't feel
like doing just like somebody a kid or a
child that doesn't want to wake up in
the morning to go to school but you make
them go to school because I the way to
success success the same thing with
adults is you know a failure is somebody
that gives to his flesh unto his body
what they want your body wants to eat
chocolate and ice cream all the time you
eat it all the time you do what you feel
like doing well that will lead you to be
in obeys and you know if you feel like
going to work you go but if you don't
feel like going don't go or if you feel
like no studying you study but if you
don't feel like studying you don't study
well if you do what you feel like doing
and you do what you know you do like
what you feel like doing all the time
you can become a failure in life but in
life you've got to do what you need to
do you've got to do what you do I won't
feel like doing but if it needs of the
doll if you need to study you study even
if you don't feel like studying if you
need to go to work and if you need to go
to work anyway if you don't feel like
going to work you go to work because I
have the right thing to do so successful
people are people who force themselves
to do the right thing to do they force
themselves to do what they need to do
rather than rather than going out there
to do only what they feel like doing but
they actually do what they don't feel
like doing because they know it is
needed to get done so you know if you
really want to be successful
life don't look for you know the easy
things and like to look for the things
that are difficult even if you don't
feel like doing it but when you do it
anyway that is the sickness the way that
is the greatest way to success
when you break your flesh when you you
humble your desires and go to do details
that you need to do even if you don't
feel like doing it well success is
hidden in the most only on you know
impossible of places in the place of
pain when you go to do things that you
don't feel like going to find success
you know the best picture you ever did
those did number one enemy you need to
counter is yourself multiple actively
trying to conquer some principalities
and powers and flights of demons and
fight some what do you call it
you know courses from inherited courses
or you know generation of course is a
physical act and you know if you
accretion you don't need to borders so
much about your generation of horses
maybe you know some people might be
having that problem but you know what I
discover I've discovered Joe you and
yourself is the biggest fight of your
life you need to conquer yourself first
the meter you put yourself in place and
begin to say and begin to talk to
yourself that's why
well I must just change myself a lot
change my habits and I woke up I must
work on my weaknesses and I won't become
a better person for myself most of our
challenges most of our troubles are
connected to us if we are not dead so
personal 12 totally Oh wholly
responsible for whatever grateful won't
we audio that there is a place there is
a role that we ourselves played in it
and if we don't think if the majority of
the blame doesn't go to us well that is
mine doesn't know it still doesn't
matter because some percentage of the
blame to go to us so it's better to
focus on ourselves and focus inside and
see what amount of the blender I carry
and then trying to go work on yourself
to eliminate and to remove some of those
things that have led you to that trouble
you I hate in the first place
so the first work you could do or in
this work if you work on yourself the
first victory you gain in this work
individual yourself you over yourself so
let us consider talking are working on
control ourselves and work and working
on on answers rather than being
considers a concern a lot other people
you are duplicate any of your life and
you know what
many of us have some dreams graduates
and many of us as some have some
aspirations great aspirations and many
of us have you are dreaming of the
coming plate people including us you
know doing a lot of great stuff but
unfortunately what I've discovered that
most of the time if we don't conquer
ourselves we cannot compare the world
around us a man that will conquer the
world much possible conquer himself if
you thought about that
if you really conquer yourself you need
to control yourself first before you
could be thinking on the for you poor
thing I'm going to conquer the world and
if you don't work on yourself if you
don't perfect yourself if you don't
train yourself if you don't discipline
yourself if you don't toot all yourself
if you don't know to administrate
yourself if you don't manage yourself
you will discover that you not be
effective in managing any other person
out there and will not be effective in
managing any other thing outside so for
us the conquered the world
Wilma's honk ourselves as a matter of
fact only the people that has conquered
themselves eventually rule
this world only need to go up conquer
themselves conquer the world only the
people who have overcome and gained
victory over themselves that the people
that have the authority in the world
because they don't have the same
challenges they don't have the same
issues
well USA well there are some people who
don't have who has not competitors but
as successful in the world but that
success if the emperor is temporary most
of the those people they are disgraced
out of those successes eventually this
is just suck success will become so low
to you if you don't conquer yourself
because it will be reviewed and you get
post
eventually if you go to surround
yourself with the right people for you
to become truly successful if anybody
you in for example if you want to become
a politician make sure that you surround
yourself
we go and find an environment exuded
where government where you can learn
from the politician and we are the
politicians who help you to advance in
your coding and your in your destiny if
you want to become a businessman so
learn yourself find yourself to go to
get yourself to where business people
and environment is a major key to
success it's one of the actually the
most important factor for success more
important and then then then then then
preparation is more important that
knowledge is very important you cannot
underestimate the role of environment
in success so you need to find people
who are already in the place where you
wish to be you need to even if you don't
have people around that are like that is
of soul and I know in your in your
environment you know if you deplete to
be a politician that the positions
aren't you go and read books of
politicians so language that will prove
subjects of great politician learn from
them that is a moment create the
environment for yourself if you don't
have been on the other and I want to
become a billionaire it will get the
boots and malnutrition of the billion
of them and 3d environments or clouds of
time and surround yourself environment
of Melania and you discovered that it is
portable so this is a major factor so
being substantial so stock sag is that
is available and actionable and success
is always even in the most unlikely of
places one of the places we have
successes eating really is in work is
having the ability to work hard and work
smart and walk more work is one of the
major instruments for success really bad
you cannot find you cannot find a truly
successful person who doesn't like to
work you cannot find a truly successful
person who is not a workaholic for you
to really be successful in life you've
got a love to work and work you must not
just anyhow become negative of work
really and then people work hard but
you've got to work smart the difference
between working smarter working hard is
to get enough knowledge about what you
want to do before you put in to do it
and when you start to do it you do it
hard and when you do it more and work
even harder
there's no way success could escape you
so if you really want to be successful
learn not just a work but learn to work
by getting first knowledge about the
nature works you want to do and to be
able to work smartly to be able to do
things strategically and that working
spot is the kind of work that you do
when you focus on the results on the
result that you get at the end of the
day and I focus on that and you work a
mean we work aiming to get the result
that you are targeting now just work for
the sake of working and of course
working hard is not to work just eight
hours a day is to work for as long as
possible just
get to where you want to get so working
hard working smart and working more is
the key to success you must stop trying
to be someone you are not
you must stop playing games on yourself
and on other people you know what most
people do are NDErs they paint a picture
of food they're really not that's why
it's a big thing to dress when you are
going out of the house why do you want
to dress well you need to make do some
makeups and remove some of the rushes
and somebody is going to do those things
but most of the time we dress to create
the wrong impression we look who behave
to create an impression rather than be
who we are because we are scared of we
are we are even scared of accepting
ourselves for who we are so we live a
deceptive lifestyle we deceiving other
people about the truth about us some
people have defeated up so much that we
will know the animal so to really
improve the life and make your life
better
you must stop trying to be in and what
you are not stop trying to create an
impression stop trying to impress
everybody stop trying to make everybody
affect you stop trying to make put off a
show stop being an actor come to realize
who you are and come to us set who you
are and if you are no good enough begin
to work on yourself to make yourself
good enough if you don't like are you up
face it that least are you are and this
is the starting point of making yourself
better stop being who you are now
stop lying
stop playing games and stop deceiving
the world and yourself then you could
begin to make yourself a better you if
you know ask information if you know it
if you have the right information about
the fake or if you know the factors of
success and easy for you to attain
success
to be successful and to become
everything that you wish to become in
life you just need to get the right
information that is when knowledge is
regarded as power knowledge is power
for those people who noticed the
importance and big and the significance
of knowledge they would never get last
never been the same they were never the
same wherever they are no matter where
you are alone in the darkest village in
Africa if you can lay your hand on
knowledge if you could go for
information information has the ability
to exhaust you information and knowledge
as the ability to ratios of that mess
and push into the light and on top of
your world
information makes the whole difference
when information comes to you it's just
this passive darkness and it brings you
into the top of your world so one of the
first factors sort of to success hour of
success and that makes success available
to you is to make yourself informed
inform yourself go for knowledge the you
know be hungry for knowledge be
exhausting for the start before
knowledge you know beyond the adventure
for knowledge if we go for knowledge if
you look for knowledge here we will see
that you will never remain where life
has put you you will always move forward
I do it the closer to success and
successful to become such a reality to
you than you ever imagined the greatest
work that you could think of into wealth
of time time is the greatest greatest
thing that you have you and I have in
our lives because time itself is equal
to mod is equal to life time is more
than money time is more than gold time
is more than precious silver
time is equal to life because our life
itself is a totality
of time so if we say is child is born
that child acted asked life in himself
but I will say the Chinese 10 years old
for example we say this child is 20
years old the baby depressor expression
is 20 years old that 20 use that word
photo or that five years we refer to 10
years that we refer to is a is a
subtotal time so if I'm saying I'm 40
years old of 43 years old
that is a subtotal of determent of blood
time that I've lived so that time equals
my life
so type this life sign whatever you do
with your time is what you do with your
life so it's waste your time you
actually within your life so if you
value your time you fund your life
eventually it's because life is a
greatest commodity it's a greatest
blessing it's a greatest treasure that
heaven and kick into all of us on the
first on earth so if you really want to
be founded about being a valuable person
you must value your time if you want
order to put on value you and to respect
you you must respect yourself by
respecting your time you find out so
think of what you do with your time on
databases how do you explain your time
do you waste your time if you waste your
time you waste your life if you waste
your time order to waste your time and
your life as well so wasting time is
actually an abuse if you don't want to
abuse yourself don't reduce your life
yeah the best thing to do is to think
about it and begin to value every minute
of the day
and don't just go about and talk don't
just grab and do just anything out there
you know you know fail twice and and
calculate like the wage by the time and
think about it before you before you you
don't do something you not think in in
the terms of the time is life I
appreciate that you have now might be
insignificant
might be small but it is those things
that you have now
that would be a blessing city tomorrow
if you want anything big in your life if
you want anything big to come to you it
will only come from the little things
that you have right now these stuff will
not come to you from our side or from
the moon or from somewhere when you've
never had it they did they smoke the
great things you ever had in your life
will grow out of it literally two things
you have right now
out of the small things that you have in
your hand so whatever you have in your
hand
you've got to treasure it whatever
things you are your hand should go to
find and then not just rather than
treasure but you've got to not check the
small things you have because the big
things that will come to you will
normally come and only will come through
those small things that are right now in
your hand and in your key as you are
fixing them through the company if you
really want to be great I'm successful
you've got to admit the litre for that
people you've got to go and help or that
people meet that meet their needs you
know to be listen of all if you want to
be the greatest it means go and help
somebody else raise of their problems so
the act of success is when we are able
to identify problems of other people and
go to help them to resolve those
problems so success is success is in
resolving problems success is when we
resolve when we hope to solve other
people's challenges and problems so you
want to really be successful well go
about go on a search go on a search for
problems and for situations where people
having needs or difficulties and go and
find and prepare yourself and find a way
of meeting those needs and resolving
those problems of people as you bring
your services or goods that will resolve
the problem of these people you will
discover that the begin to thank you
everything to show the appreciation in
the informs of our enumeration salary or
honorarium
we'll begin to pay you or to compensate
you for your efforts and for your
services so now if your purpose in doing
this it's not just to get money to get
the nomination if you just go to resolve
the problems and to provide solution and
answers you discover that you keep on
getting more skills and you keep on
getting more recognition and not just
recognition and skills but you keep on
getting a salary or money or
compensation for your efforts and that
will keep on listening you of the more
you do the more you sacrifice yourself
for the others the more that you
experience real success so success is
going to find a need and make it and you
success what's much my country
thank you guys so much for watching I
made this video because Nicki Ruo Jie
meizu asked me to so there's someone
you'd like me to cover in the next top
ten video check out the link in the
description and go and cast your vote I
also want to give a quick shout out to
skip Prichard skip thank you so much for
picking up a copy of my book your one
word and taking that picture and posting
it to your Twitter
I really really appreciate the support
and I hope you enjoyed the read so thank
you guys again for watching I believe in
you I hope we continue to believe in
yourself and whatever your one word is
much love I'll see you soon
you've got to be proactive he's got to
be proper to a plethora because I've
become a person of action if you really
want to attend it subsides if you really
want to miss a person I move for what if
anything you're doing your old life
you've got to make sure that you have
personal touches that you are proactive
you don't wait for people to tell you
what to do you don't wait to get a
command from anybody but you stand and
go and do what you need to do you be
proactive you initiate changes you
initiate a move you know be ready to go
out and do as much work as possible the
apostle of action you know the Bible
tells us that the hand of blazing brings
poverty but the hand of the diligent
based wealth and reach it the diligent
in everything you do
be a person of diligence be somebody
that we do you know if you need to work
for eight hours or for 10 hours if you
need to do ten works do 20 works just
make sure that good at and you do better
than any other person Alan you know when
I was in the university when I came from
Africa to study in Europe I knew for me
to get anywhere I must become the back
today the university I must beat all the
students from every other country
because I'm a black person and if I
really want to make a difference in this
world if I really want to you know make
a lasting impact if I want my Jesus
would be proud of me and if I don't want
to be ashamed I mean for him to be
ashamed of me or for the water be
ashamed of him I must make I must make
sure that I store the extra class I
started short time and ask you to become
the best in your field so be proactive
and be a person of action and success
will be available and ready for you you
preparation is a king and a major key to
prep to success in life you can become
great in life you could become
successful in life only be adequately
prepared many people do things sharply
many people do things on the surface
many people just do things to get by it
and you just you know to just much to
get a mark that they have
people go to school and just you know
give exams I think they are doing it for
the teacher people go to school and you
know just play around in the schools
people go no to universities and don't
give their best they are not adequately
prepared and they are still dreaming and
yet the a dreaming of being successful
in life
well success is not possible to just
anybody
success comes to people who fulfilled
conditions of success success come to
people who do and by themselves by the
loss of success yesterday we spoke about
the more information and the power of
knowledge and the role it plays in in
success but today we're talking about
the importance of preparation you need
to get yourself prepared you need to be
the best you could be in everything you
do you need to make sure that you don't
just jump into doing something but you
make sure that you first of all prepare
yourself you make sure you have an
adequate preparation before you start to
you know your embark on any journey or
any activity or anything whatsoever you
do like the principle that this most
people use sports men who win the
Olympics they you spend it in your maybe
two three four years per curiam spend up
to five ten years preparing themselves
rigorously before they go and compete in
their in their anything whatever suppose
they're complicated
so preparation there is nothing but
where preparation is a would to success
the parijatham oompa success so let's
get prepared adequately before we are
engaged in anything that is another
major factor to success if you really
want to be successful you must be
diligent enough to go through the
process many diff we just want to wake
up one morning and just wake up being
successful or wake up them big wake up
being great and just have everything at
once
no that is reception you cannot have
everything just at once you must be know
willing and ready to paint things
painstakingly go through the process of
production you must not be one of those
ones that want to have something for
nothing you must not be one of those
people that
to have something where you don't pay
the price for it you must be willing to
pay the price for anything that you
desire to have in life don't just have a
goal but they willing to walk and go
through the process of a pain of
endurance of sacrifice of a label of
work just make sure you follow the order
make sure you follow the rules make sure
you follow due process so that you'll be
able to get where you want to go because
that is the only thing that can assure
you or give you a lasting success so you
must be a person of process you must be
follow you must be diligent you must
learn to pay attention to details
undermine moves insignificant things so
you must pay attention to the details
and the process of creation the process
of production the process from getting
to a from A to B must be so low you must
make sure that you follow the rules you
must make sure that you don't omit any
single or any small point in your quest
to go and get to where you wish to find
yourself so B X our own diligent process
diligence and then follow the follow
through the process is a major factor
just to becoming successful in life